A HAPPY EASTER.
LELAND:  YOU AS WELL.
BILL.
GILLIAN.
GILLIAN:  SEVERAL BIOTECH
COMPANIES ARE BEGINNING CLINICAL
TRIALS OF VACCINES AND
TREATMENTS AS THE CORONAVIRUS
CONTINUES TO SPREAD AT
UNPRECEDENTED RATES WORLDWIDE.
FOR MORE INSIGHT ON THIS WE’RE
GOING TO BRING IN FORMER FDA
ASSOCIATE COMMISSIONER, HE’S
ALSO PRESIDENT OF THE CENTER FOR
MEDICINE IN THE PUBLIC INTEREST,
PETER PICK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
TODAY.
THERE’S THIS RACE ACROSS THE
GLOBE TO GET TO A VACCINE.
HEARING DIFFERENT OFFICIALS GIVE
US DIFFERENT NUMBERS, DIFFERENT
-- VAIR I VARYING LENGTHS OF TIM
FAR WE ARE FROM THAT.
THE QUESTION THAT MATTERS MOST
TO AMERICANS IS NOT WHEN THERE
WILL BE A VACCINE, BUT WHEN
THERE WILL BE A VACCINE THAT IS
APPROVED FOR WIDESPREAD USE.
WHAT’S YOUR BEST GUESSTIMATE ON
THAT NOW?
>> YOU KNOW, THERE’S A LOT OF
GOOD NEWS HERE.
BIOTECH COMPANIES ARE WORKING
WITH GOVERNMENTS AND REGULATORY
AGENCIES AND ACADEMIA ALL AROUND
THE WORLD TO GET THE VACCINE
DONE, TO GET THERAPEUTICS
INVENTED.
THE FDA IN THE U.S. IS WORKING
24 HOURS A DAY, AROUND THE
CLOCK, MAKING SURE THAT
EXPERIMENTAL MEDICINES GET
THROUGH THE SYSTEM, EXISTING
MEDICINES ARE GETTING EMERGENCY
USE EXEMPTIONS TO DOCTORS HAVE
THE TOOLS THEY NEED TO FIGHT FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE THE MOST ILL,
PEOPLE IN THE HOSPITAL, OLDER
PEOPLE, PRE-EXISTING CONDITIONS.
CHLOROQUINE IS UNDERGOING SOLID
RESEARCH AND BEING USED IN
CLINIC RIGHT NOW.
YOU CAN’T BASE THESE THINGS
PURELY ON ANECDOTE.
WE ARE DOING THE RIGHT THING
WHEN IT COMES TO TESTING.
SIMILARLY, WHETHER IT’S TESTING
THAT SHOWS POSITIVE OR NEGATIVE
OR WHETHER IT’S PLASMA ANTIBODY
TESTING, THOSE TESTS ARE SPED
FORWARD.
MY GUESS RELATIVE TO A VACCINE
IS PROBABLY 10 MONTHS TO A YEAR.
FOR VACCINES THAT’S PRETTY FAST.
I THINK THERE’S SOLID CAUSE FOR
OPTIMISM.
>> .GILLIAN: WELL, NOW THERE’S
RACE TO THE VACCINE.
YOU SAY THAT’S 10 TO 12 MONTHS
OUT.
THERE’S ALSO THESE ANTIBODY
TESTS THAT YOU MENTIONED.
WE KEEP HEARING ABOUT THEM.
TAKE A LISTEN TO DR. ANTHONY
FAUCI, A COUPLE DAYS AGO, ON
THESE TESTS.
I’LL GET YOUR REACTION ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
>> WITHIN A PERIOD OF A WEEK OR
SO, WE’RE GOING TO HAVE A RATHER
LARGE NUMBER OF TESTS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE.
THESE ANTIBODY TESTS ARE TESTS
THAT WE DO ON OTHER DISEASES BUT
THEY NEED TO BE VALIDATED.
YOU NEED TO MAKE SURE THEY’RE
CONSISTENT AND THEY’RE ACCURATE.
AND THAT’S WHAT WE’RE DOING NOW.
BOTH WITH THE NIH AND WITH THE
FDA.
GILLIAN:  SO UNPACK THAT A
LITTLE BIT FOR US.
TALK TO US IN REAL SPEAK ABOUT
WHAT THIS MEANS FOR AMERICANS.
>> WELL, FIRSTLY, WHAT
DR. FAUCI IS SAYING YOU DON’T
WANT TESTS APPROVED THAT ARE
INACCURATE.
YOU WANT TO EXPEDITE BUT NOT
RUSH AND THAT’S WHAT’S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW AND THAT TAKES A TEAM
EFFORT TO MAKE SURE IT’S
HAPPENING AND IT IS.
BUT THE IMPORTANCE OF THESE
ANTIBODY TESTS IS IT DOESN’T
NECESSARILY SHOW WHETHER YOU’RE
POSITIVE OR NEGATIVE.
IT SHOWS WHETHER OR NOT YOU’VE
ALREADY HAD THE DISEASE AND
THAT’S IMPORTANT FOR TWO
REASONS.
THE FIRST IS THE BLOOD PLASMA,
THE ANTIBODIES FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAVE COME THROUGH TO THE OTHER
END OF THE TUNNEL MIGHT GIVE
PATIENTS A BIT OF IMMUNITY,
MIGHT MAKE THE COURSE OF THE
DISEASE EASIER TO HANDLE.
IT WILL GIVE US AN IDEA HOW MANY
AMERICANS HAVE HAD THE DISEASE.
THAT’S A KEY DATA POINT RELATIVE
TO WHEN WE CAN REOPEN OUR
ECONOMY.
GILLIAN:  THERE’S THIS
CONTINUING SAGA FOR LACK OF A
BETTER WORD WITH
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP KEEPS TOUTING IT
AND THE TASK FORCE BRIEFINGS AS
A VIABLE TREATMENT.
HE WANTS MORE PEOPLE TO START
USING IT.
BUT A LOT OF MEDICAL EXPERTS SAY
IT HASN’T BEEN TESTED ENOUGH.
IT’S BEEN TESTED BUT NOT
CLINICALLY.
WHAT’S YOUR TAKE ON THAT?
>> THE DATA THAT’S OUT THERE
RIGHT NOW IS PURELY ANECDOTAL.
THERE’S NO REAL SOLID SCIENCE
BEHIND IT THAT YOU CAN BUILD A
FOUNDATION ON BUT WE’RE
COLLECTING IT.
SHOULD IT BE USED?
I THINK DOCTORS HAVE THE OPTION
TO USE IT FOR THEIR PATIENTS.
AN IMPORTANT POINT HERE IS THAT
THIS IS A MEDICINE THAT’S BEING
USED FOR PATIENTS WITH A CHRONIC
CONDITION SUCH AS LUPUS AND
RHEUMATOID ARTHRITIS.
WE DON’T WANT SHORTAGES.
WE DON’T WANT PEOPLE TO DEMAND
THESE DRUGS.
85% OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE COVID-19
WILL RIDE IT OUT AT HOME WITH
PLENTY OF LIQUIDS AND THEY WON’T
NEED CHLOROQUINE.
DOCTORS HAVE IT AS A TOOL FOR
THE MOST SERIOUSLY ILL PATIENTS
WHO REALLY NEED IT TO SURVIVE.
GILLIAN:  SOUNDS LIKE RISKS
THERE WITH USING
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE ARE NOT JUST
TO THE USERS BUT CONCERNS ABOUT
CAUSING A SHORTAGE FOR OTHER
MEDICAL PATIENTS WHO RELY ON IT
TO STAY HEALTHY THEMSELVES,
INDEPENDENTLY OF COVID-19 AND
THE CORONAVIRUS.
PETER, THANKS SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND YOUR EXPERTISE TODAY.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
>> MY PLEASURE.